people have very strong emotional
reactions to sound some sounds remind us
of our childhood some sounds are very
relaxing the sounds can be scary sounds
can be romantic and everything in
between I approached the fifth last fall
about this idea of a collaboration
between my course experimental sound
synthesis and the FIPS with the idea
being that the students could create
some kind of sound installation that
would integrate into one of the spaces
at the tips and we could do this
collaboration in the butterfly force in
the stove room which is one of the
oldest Victorian glass houses in the
United States the sound art installation
has really transformed the space it's
really neat to pair the motion of the
butterflies flying around the living
plants and then this third element of
the sound
when you ask yourself what would be the
sound of a butterfly you have to start
thinking a little bit metaphorically
butterflies are colorful flying
fluttering transformative so when you
start using terms like that maybe make
sense to a composer you could inspire
something so we wanted to do something
that was more interesting than just a
sound playing in a loop we sought out to
create sound pieces that would be
continuously evolving so that these
sound scapes would be never repeating
themselves what's really significant is
how the students were able to break down
the experiences into 11 different
individual experiences through that room
so as you move through that room you
definitely experience something
different in each space what you're
hearing in our work is a combination of
skills from composing and sound design
and computer science because the
students created programs that could
either synthesize or transform or filter
all these different banks of sounds that
they created having a partnership with
CMU in any capacity is always great
because of the proximity because of the
creativity and it's great for us to
provide a unique environment for CMU
students to work in as well
it's just always a nice experience for
us
you
[Music]